so when you saw this film for the first
time we've all seen it well I'm saying
it's a lot but if he's the first time
oh no I've seen but I've seen bits and
I'm seeing yeah yeah yeah so when you
saw that that CG will and you know maybe
had the double take as an actor did you
think yourself oh man we're all in for a
now listen the idea that I can get
employed and work on a movie and not
have to leave my house is fine by me I
just looked at a script and go yeah I'll
do that one I'll stay home and you pay
me that's that's a great future as a
viewer we see like the tech evolve over
time right obviously the CG getting
better and now this the 3d hundred
twenty frames per second but as an actor
when you're working with someone who's
wearing like all this gear right like
well we saw him wearing like this gear
that does that affect your performance
or how does that affect if it doesn't
actually know and that's partly creditor
will lose such a great actor and he's so
focused and disciplined and like the
ultimate pro so he comes into a scene
like that and he's got the gear on but
the minute we start doing the scene he's
just in the zone and acting and very
quickly all that stuff disappears I mean
you know whenever movie you make a film
like this or you know there are always
extraneous things going on in some way
or another and actors just have to get
in there and do what they do and
ultimately all of that stuff if you're
doing it right and your focus disappears
yeah would you want to be 23 again uh no
I don't think so no because people are
always like because then I wouldn't have
kids and I love my kids what are you
better at now then do you were acting
three
hopefully but this is them underneath
all of that wizardry this is still like
a tight thriller movie and we've seen
you in these sorts of films before all
this intrigue in this espionage what do
you like about this genre this style of
film um I don't know I mean each film
comes at you in a different way with
different people attached and different
you know things and this one was you
know I'd worked a little with Aang many
years ago on on this I did this campaign
for being dog in short these movies and
Aang did one and slightly disconcerting
thing is his little boy was in that one
who's now a full-grown adult acting away
it's just a little weird but um and you
know you look at a film like this and
you go that's you know he's the perfect
guy to do a film like this because he's
so excited and interested in pushing the
boundaries of what's technically
achievable with film but he's a true
artist who cares about script and about
character and about so you know you're
doing this huge movie but he's also
incredibly detailed and specific yeah
with all this focus on how the film
looks and the techniques behind it do
you think this is what we're gonna be
seeing movies look like in the future I
know he hangs convinced and convinced
these at the beginning of something he
thinks I understand his impulse in
thinking that something's got to change
to get people into the cinema because
you know you know our viewing habits
have changed so much we want things so
quickly and accessible I mean we just
sort of to get people out and get him
into the cinema something's got to
change they've got a you know and a film
like this it is an event to see it in
his full glory how it was perceived and
projected in the right way is a
different experience and it would be
watching it in any other way so I
understand that impulse but um you know
and and as I say I had many discussions
with him and he thinks he's at the
beginning of something that shift
yeah it's called be here for it the
earth awesome thanks man just just
amazed
you